American society seems to be fraying at
the edges but filmmaker Michael Moore
believes he's part of the solution he is
the hero who can help save it
watch him describe his role earlier this
year we must also cleanse our American
soul of its white male privilege its
voracious greed and its enforced
ignorant that has made a population of
semi-literate and unaware people Michael
Moore the soul cleanser one of the
things rotting our soul he just said is
greed and yet many people close to more
people who would no say that he himself
is Exhibit A for that problem
for example his film festival has just
been sued for allegedly failing to pay
vendors the little people and instead
smearing them in the press meanwhile
Moore's ex-wife says that he stiffed her
on the profits from the films she helped
produce those would include Bowling for
Columbine in Fahrenheit 9/11 Greg
Gutfeld has long made a passion of
studying the career of Michael Moore he
also hosts the five on Fox as well as
where a gutful Joe and he joins us
tonight so I'm a little confused by this
Greg Michael Moore one thing we know
about him is he's a champion of the
people
so why isn't he championing individual
people and instead scamming them they
say well that that's where you're wrong
he's a man of the people unless those
people are working for him then he will
shack them to pay for his pies because
he loves his pies you know what here's
that it's the truth of the activists
Tucker they think globally but they're
jerks locally the act the act of caring
actually excuses their own obnoxious
self-involved arrogant behavior if you
ever were in college you know this you
always if you had a roommate that was an
activist they would go to the peace
marches but they would never pay their
rent on time
they never spring for the toilet paper
and they always ate your food Tucker I'm
also worried because Michael Moore is
looking Mort it's true but Michael Moore
is looking more and more like Large
Marge from pee-wee's Playhouse the movie
pee-wee's great adventure remember large
March the truck driver
maybe the sides on the sequel maybe and
by the way he co he believes that the
world's coming to an end why is it that
people who think they're so brilliant
and they think that the world is coming
to an end
they never bathe or wear fresh underwear
well maybe that's why because it's not
worth it
but wait they're still sort of confused
by this so if you really cared about the
world and making it better wouldn't you
begin with the people around you they're
unimportant
Tucker they're unimportant because you
have a greater mission in life and that
is to save the world
therefore you can be mean to your wife
you could ignore your kids you could
cheat you could be terrible and by the
way Tucker you're not so perfect
yourself you know what you know what
yesterday was Tucker do you know what
yesterday man-of-the-people Tucker
Tucker it was my birthday
did I hear from Tucker Karl yes you did
I texted you
happy 30th birthday yes I waited I
waited I was playing our song you love
your favorite shirt phone in a bar and
you know it anyway so I want to ask you
this because you're the perfect person
to ask your very shortly in the show
we're gonna speak to stormy Daniels his
attorneys just right if you were sitting
in this chair what would you ask him I
would you know he's a porn expert so I
would ask him how do you permanently
erase your browser history because I'm
always interested in that that's a
question a lot of my friends asked me
that question no here's what I'm
complaining you know I got nothing
against porn but this is a highly
immoral activity that stormy Daniels is
participating in it's not adult films
it's that you reneged on a deal she is a
she is a paid sex worker she gets paid
for sex isn't that what this is what is
she mad about I don't understand what
did Trump do he people that she's a real
question what is it and that's a sincere
question but I feel sorry for stormy
Daniels I think she's being exploited by
yes absolutely absolutely I don't
understand what the injury to her was
that nothing Nina do you know it's like
it's it's a D it was a deal that they
made and I think it's maybe she's mad
that he she could have gotten more money
out of it then she did because he became
president maybe that's why
she's upset the other sad thing about
porn is that no one ever retires they
always tried it though the whole thing
is they try to get out of porn
everything's about Getty can't be a good
vocation if the first goal is to get out
of it it's true whereas no one ever
wants to get on television no that's
true we're dying now I will you'll have
to carry me out here on a stretcher
you only get fired that's the only way
out exactly you felt great to see you oh
it's a pleasure and thanks for the gift